[Musique]
m
algérie europe tels ont été les deux
sujets qu'avec monsieur louis joxe un
ancien gaston palewski un nouveau edgard
pisani un ancien monsieur georges
pompidou étudier au cours de son premier
conseil des ministres le premier conseil
des ministres du deuxième gouvernement
de la vème république
de monsieur alain peyrefitte à jacques
mayol on a pu à cette occasion découvrir
les neuf nouveaux visages de l'équipe
gouvernementale neuf nouveaux visages
qui ne sont pas tous inconnus puisque le
gouvernement compte messieurs pierre
pflimlin et maurice schumann
le général salan que l'on connu comme le
général le plus décoré de l'armée
française est aujourd'hui arrêté puis en
la france il s'était un temps installé
en espagne et il y avait réuni les
premiers fils d'une conjuration se
proposait de soulever l'algérie cette
conjuration de manas au putsch du 22
avril ou du balcon de la délégation
générale il apparut pour haranguer la
foule on sait comment ce terminal
aventure
caisse pire est il de son action
terroriste loving algérie las de tant de
sang répandu et d'une france qui avait
donné au général de bull lobby mastic du
référé aujourd'hui c'est la fin
l'ex-général ça n'en était conduit la
santé derrière les murs de sa prison le
chef de l'oas attend ses juges
[Musique]
en angleterre on prépare activement pour
le marché connaît la sortie de la
voiture à turbine ce prototype vient de
partir pour les états unis où l'on
compte qu'il se fera également remarque
le conducteur n'aura plus que deux
pédales actionnées l'accélérateur et le
frein mais surtout plus de cylindres
plus de piston plus de carburateur
un progrès dans le sens de la
simplification
dans le domaine de l'aviation
l'angleterre encore vient de présenter
un nouveau modèle dont l'ambition est la
vitesse le bristol 188 a été construit
en acier inoxydable pour lui permettre
de franchir le mur de la chaleur après
le mur du son et du même coup de
s'offrir une vitesse égale à trois fois
la vitesse du son
il faut donner un souvenir ému à pierre
larquey qui dans sa villa de maisons
laffitte vient de s'éteindre à soixante
dix huit ans après avoir personnifié
dans 250 films et plus la gentillesse la
bonne amie la tendresse humaine qu'il
incarnait aussi dans la vie
par vous par votre présence le grand
père du cinéma
toute l'espagne pendant la semaine
sainte célèbrent la passion du christ
non madrid la nuit du vendredi une
longue procession parcourent les rues
ça tu portais sur des chars illuminés
litan à kaboul porteur de cierges réalit
comme au siècle passé 7 de passion qui
chez les chrétiens le sommet religieux
de l'année
en italie près de naples les paysans du
village de nola seront honorés au sommet
d'une colline d à peine notre dame des
sept douleurs ces pèlerins ont fait le
voeu deal et le chapelle à la madone
vénéré
et par centaines les femmes en forme de
pénitence y apportent leur pierre
tradition émouvante mais qui laisse
perplexe n'y a t'il là-bas que les
femmes qui pêche ou qu'ils se repentent
[Musique]
on savait que la profession de nurse
était dignement honoré en grande
bretagne vous ne savez peut-être pas que
l'exigeait des capacités sportives
particulière mais ce ne peut être que
dans un loi de l'esprit d'émulation qui
est organisée dans le comté d'essex
cette course de voitures d'enfants ou
fait remarquable mais qui ne doit plus
nous surprendre à l'époque des femmes
soldats les concurrents masculins
étaient amis
14 km 400 à couvrir et à leur terme une
heure de gloire pour ceux et celles qui
étaient parvenus à mener à bon port
matériel et chargement
[Musique]
à peine sortis de leur voiture les
enfants américains ceux du moins des
maradona en sont déjà à s'expliquer sur
un ring avec aux mains des gants gros
comme la tête
par ces temps de guerre froide endémique
il n'est sans doute pas mauvais de
laisser librement la combativité se
révéler dès le plus jeune âge et la
preuve est faite en tout pas que les
jeunes générations ne mentent pas reste
que le métier de parent n'apparaît pas
après ses démonstrations comme devant
être des plus tranquilles
[Applaudissements]
la neige d'avril qui aura permis cette
année de prolonger les sports d'hiver
jusqu'à pâques nous a valu de rencontrer
dans les alpes à un skieur dont le moins
qu'on puisse dire est qu'il a une
technique très personnelle jaloux
tournier voyez plutôt
[Musique]
où
sa technique pour n'avoir aucun rapport
avec celle de l'oeuf cher à nos
champions n'en garde pas moins une
efficacité certaine encore que
déroutante
[Musique]
cet acrobate des neiges a aussi plus
d'un tour dans son sac
[Musique]
m
avec jeannot tournier sans doute faut-il
ne cette année de rang
après cela que voulez vous il faudra
bien se dire que tout sur l'éducation
est à refaire et dans le commencement
[Musique]
c'est un simple village de la campagne
tourangelle quelques vieilles fermes
abandonnées
mais on peut dormir dans les greniers
pour peu qu ans armes contre les rats et
qu'on s'arrange d'un confort sommaire il
ya maintenant cinq ans trois jeunes
femmes se tard ce raisonnement et avant
donnant à la fois l'école des beaux-arts
et la vie parisienne var s'installer à
la martinerie et depuis on peut voir
chaque matin l'une ou l'autre vaquer aux
besoins de la communauté
ce fut d'abord un mystère pour les gens
du pays puis on s'habitue à ont compris
que les trois demoiselles de la
martinerie comme on les appelle n'était
pas venu là sur un caprice mais qu'elle
était venue chercher un refuge pour
leurs travaux
pour le matin elle commence à tirer leur
est faux car ils se sont jouées un art
très ancien la tapisserie à l'éguille et
en cinq ans de geste patients identiques
à ceux qui au moyen âge ont donné la
tapisserie de bayeux elles ont redonné à
cet art une nouvelle gloire
[Musique]
le résultat de leurs travaux ornent
aujourd'hui les murs d'une galerie
parisienne etc communal de proposer aux
hommes emportés par la vie moderne au
travers de sujets aussi simple que le
bien et le mal la lumière et les
ténèbres la sagesse et l'amour les
doigts zèle de l'usiné ou renouer avec
l'inspiration des fresques romanes et
des mosaïques byzantines
et donner à leurs oeuvres
cette grâce inimitable la vie
et
[Musique]